[Music]
before we set this video I just want to
mention that only 16% of you are
subscribed so if you enjoy the content
please hit the subscribe button hey
everyone welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing the five
most powerful witches wizards that came
from Gryffindor House at Hogwarts in the
last video we discussed Slytherin and
you guys seem to enjoy it so I'm going
to be making one of these videos for
each of the four houses now of the four
houses with those who are destined to be
sovereigns aside Gryffindor is seemingly
the house that many people want to be in
sure it's not for everyone but in a
weird way it's sort of the popular house
that gets all of the glory in
McGonigle's own words though she might
be biased having been christened or
herself the house of God Rick Griffin
doll has commanded the respect of the
Wizarding World for nearly 10 centuries
many of the other houses over the years
speculated that Gryffindor has received
favoritism from the Hogwarts staff
however despite their differences with
Gryffindor Hufflepuff and ravenclaw have
also always been on the side of
Gryffindor in the ongoing rivalry
between Slytherin and Gryffindor the
sorting hat describes the criteria for
Gryffindor as follows you might belong
in Gryffindor where dwelled the brave at
heart their daring nerve and chivalry
set Gryffindor's apart in short what
this basically means is a defining
characteristic of a Gryffindor is
courage or bravery Hogwarts had four
founders Rowena Ravenclaw South's a
Slytherin Elgar Hufflepuff and Godric
Gryffindor each of the four founders
formed their very own house at the
school and Gryffindor House which of
course found it by Godric after founding
the school the four founders encountered
a bit of a dilemma when it occurred to
them that it would have to figure out a
way to sort students by house when they
were no longer alive however this
dilemma was short-lived as Godric
Gryffindor quickly provided a solution
to their problem Godric pulled his
completely normal hat off of his head
and made the suggestion to the other
founders that using their collective
magic they enchant the Hat and turn it
into a sentient being the four founders
of Hogwarts
recognized that they
valued very different virtues virtues
which ended up leading to the defining
attributes of each house it was
important to them that the houses they
founded would continue to follow by the
beliefs from which they were based these
virtues or inherent characteristics can
be summed up in the sorting hats own
words by Gryffindor the bravest were
prized far beyond the rest for ravenclaw
the cleverest would always be the best
for Hufflepuff hard workers were must
worthy of admission and power-hungry
sovereign loved those of great ambition
there it is again
prized far beyond the rest boy after the
students placed the hat on their head it
begins to analyze their mind and places
them in a house based on how closely
they resemble one of the four founders
in the same way that becoming evil is
not a defining characteristic of cedron
being arrogant is not a defining
characteristic of a Gryffindor and this
is the reputation that they seem to get
like so they're in Gryffindor houses
produced some of the greatest and most
powerful wizards the world has ever seen
one of the reasons that Gryffindor
students and southern students have such
a seemingly embedded rivalry is because
Hogwarts founders Godric Gryffindor and
Salazar Slytherin had a falling out of a
sovereign's emphasis on blood purity
despite their courageous reputation some
feel that their courage is mainly
exercised by engaging in pointless
heroics and Severus Snape always found
Gryffindor's to be self-righteous and
arrogant though he could just be saying
this because he disliked the Marauders
the top 5 list for Gryffindor was
actually much harder to produce than a
list for Sutherland as I feel that there
are many witches and wizards from
Gryffindor House is it quite comparable
in terms of power
there are also some characters that I
feel like should be in Gryffindor but we
just don't have any proof to support it
ie Rufus Scrimgeour he was such a
powerful wizard and if he was a
Gryffindor which he might have been he
definitely would have made this list
though I know that some feel he was more
of a southern maybe there's a topic for
another video so without further ado
let's take a look the five most powerful
Gryffindor's to have ever lived at least
the ones that we know about number 5
Sirius Black first of all let me start
off by saying that it was really hard
for me to decide between Remus and
Sirius this position on the list
they grew up together in the booth
particularly powerful wizards in their
own right Remus has the added threat of
being able to transform into a werewolf
but I think that serious and this is
just my opinion is a slightly more
powerful one out of the pair we know
Sirius Black as The Godfather of Harry
Potter and one of the Marauders series
started at Hogwarts in the year 1971 the
same year that Peter Pettigrew Remus
Lupin and James Potter began attending
the school the quartet of boys would
eventually form a group called Marauders
and one thing that they all had in
common was they were all Gryffindor's
the Marauders were hell-bent on breaking
the rules at the school and were
notorious for their rule breaking and
mischief making though they were
mischief makers they were all very
magically talented and serious ended up
becoming an animagus the ripe age of 15
an extremely impressive feat his
animagus form is a black dog and it was
by transforming into his animagus form
then he was able to escape through the
bars at Azkaban Sirius hailed from the
powerful visiting family the blacks and
while many of his family members placed
an unreasonable amount of value on blood
purity series did not share this same
belief many of the members of the black
family went down a very dark path
serious cousin Bellatrix Lestrange is a
great example of this serious didn't
want his lineage to determine the man
that he would become and once wisely
said we've all got both light and dark
inside us what matters is the part we
choose to act on that's who we really
are
while his magical development was
somewhat stunted by the extensive amount
of time that he spent in Azkaban he
still ended up being a supremely
powerful wizard in addition to becoming
an animagus Sirius was skilled at
Transfiguration in general not only that
but he was also skilled at brewing
potions producing charms producing
nonverbal magic and Aquaman see Sirius
met his demise at the hands of his
cousin Bellatrix but she's one of the
most powerful witches to have ever lived
so it's not like he went down easy
number four Peter Pettigrew I know what
you're thinking Peter Pettigrew how is
he on this list just hear me out Peter
Pettigrew also known as Wormtail was a
British pure but wizard born in 1959 he
had pale skin unhealthy hair and blue
eyes too most he was considered to be a
sniveling excuse for a man
whose loyalties only lay where there was
power but in his younger years he did
sort of have friends and was one of the
members of the Marauders along with
Sirius Remus and James Pettigrew like
Sirius successfully became an animagus
at a very young age and although it took
Pettigrew longer than Sirius it doesn't
automatically mean that Sirius was a
more gifted wizard many witches and
wizards as well as fans of the series
automatically right off Pettigrew's
magical capabilities due to his
appearance and meek demeanor however the
truth is that Pettigrew was a talented
wizard he was also just equally mentally
weak and quite impressionable Pettigrew
didn't perform well at school but it
seemed like during his time at school he
was more focused on just causing trouble
with his friends additionally some
people just struggle in their younger
years and go on to accomplish greater
and more impressive things once they've
gotten a little bit older I think that
Pettigrew fits this category perfectly
in addition to becoming an animagus
which is an advanced form of
Transfiguration Pettigrew was also first
in conjuration another extremely
advanced branch of Transfiguration
conjuration which allows individuals to
transfigure an object out of thin air
was only taught to talented students at
the newt level he could also brew highly
advanced potions under the instruction
of Lord Voldemort he successfully helped
to produce both the rudimentary body
potion and regeneration potion he also
along with Barty Crouch jr. produced a
Polyjuice potion which is very involved
though I don't necessarily believe that
Pettigrew is much more powerful than
Sirius or Remus with regards to
conventional forms of magic I do think
that he is much more versed in the dark
arts as neither Sirius nor Remus had
much experience with the dark arts
Pettigrew could easily and successfully
cast
Avada Kedavra which requires extreme
concentration additionally in 1981 the
same year the Pettigrew frame Sirius for
the death of 12 muggles he utilized the
dark advanced and powerful blasting
curse the curse was strong enough to
murder twelve people destroy hundreds of
feet of sewer system and leave a 40-foot
crater in the ground because he had such
a broad Wizarding Arsenal I think that
he is deserving of the number-4 spot on
this list
number three Minerva McGonagall Minerva
McGonagall is a Scottish half fat witch
that attended the Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry and later worked
there while she attended the school she
was the most talented student of her
entire year and she achieved top grades
in her newts and owls she exhibited
extreme magical prowess from a very
young age and later became one of
Hogwarts best professors McGonigle's
most notable skill is perhaps related to
her knowledge and talent in
transfiguration she is known for her
effortless ability to transform her
physical form at will
McGonigle was extremely proficient at
transfiguration
very early on and she became an animagus
at a very young age she later became a
head of transfiguration at Hogwarts a
position that she took very seriously as
she believed Transfiguration be one of
the most complex and dangerous forms of
magic taught at the school she was also
highly proficient at casting a wide
variety of charms and mastered the
Patronus charm in both corporeal and
incorporeal forms when she was still
very young she was also a skilled potion
maker able to successfully brew an
animagus potion and dualist notably Zhu
Ling Lord Voldemort to a standstill
alongside Slughorn and Kingsley but what
makes McGonagall particularly powerful
is her paired knowledge of the dark arts
not only did she master charms
Transfiguration dueling and potion
making she also had a vast knowledge of
the dark arts though she didn't use dark
spells frequently she could use them
when necessary and notably used the
Imperius curse on amicus Cara number two
Godric Gryffindor we don't actually have
a lot of information on Godric
Gryffindor but we know that the founders
of Hogwarts all four of them were
immensely powerful the Hogwarts founders
are widely thought to have possessed
power that was entirely and comparable
to most modern-day witches and wizards
Godric was a tall muscular man was a
lion like mane of hair this is
representative of the Gryffindor crest
which contains a lion Gryffindor was
unusual as a wizard and that he would
often duel with the sword rather fertile
wand this was to give people a fighting
chance he was also an extremely
impressive swordsman and his sword the
Sword of Gryffindor
is massively important in
the series Godric was also a charms
master and along with the other three
founders helped him chant the sorting
hat effectively turning it into a
sentient being funnily enough who was
actually his hat to begin with like I
said before we just don't have a lot of
information on the man but I still think
that I can confidently place him this
high up in the list because time and
time again the founders have been
referenced as exceedingly powerful
Rowling herself said that Gryffindor was
the most accomplished jeweler of his
time number one
Dumbledore now I'm sure you saw this
coming D'Amato is undoubtedly the most
powerful wizard to have ever lived
comparable only to maybe Voldemort or
possibly Grindle wat while at school
Dumbledore's magical abilities
consistently turn heads particularly his
skills surrounding charms and
Transfiguration he also did
exceptionally well on his newts and
Griselda Marchbanks
a professor working for the Wizarding
examinations authority remark that Albus
was able to do things with the wand that
she had never seen before in addition to
being a charms and Transfiguration
master gum model was also an expert
practitioner of elemental magic over the
course of the books and films he's
really shown us what he's capable of and
in his jewel against Voldemort in the
ministry atrium we see his elemental
expertise shine through and he creates
some sort of complicated hydrokinetic
spell I think that his most impressive
display of magic period was when he
produced firestorm to ward off the in
faerie firestorm produces a large ring
of fire from the caster's wand and from
this ring the caster is able to shoot
Jets or balls of fire at opponents there
truly isn't a subject or area of magic
where Dumbledore is lacking and he's
truly a master in Transfiguration charms
potions elemental magic ah clemency and
more he is the exception to the phrase
jack of all trades master of none
as he was truly a jack of all trades
master of all and that's it for this
list honorable mentions include Harry
Potter Hermione Granger Remus Lupin and
James Potter this is not to say that
there aren't other powerful Gryffindor's
these are just the ones that nearly made
the
what do you guys think who were your top
five let me know down in the comment
section below
until next time your wizard Ari